analyzing right love follow the air here
your like doing he knows the destination
only between brazil and
there
and you will find in the people
our doctors eight she in bed here i
need to use them is not
joão yet you were already you  I was going to win the
new countries died video then I went to pray
that there oh man what a shot was this one
to grow almeida romana and
I don't know yet it's still not one more
the dangerous are some appearing without the
part of the world micos give me one more
I won't even be  henrique nylon red home
live in
[Music]
call me now adding norma there in the middle
since they are joaquim i
the bandits write fiction and
a look at theirs is
what it is